EU employment and social affairs
ministers have reached an informal
agreement on new rules to improve the
European employment services network
known as us at their council in Brussels
the aims to make the labour mobility
network more efficient getting more job
postings and CVS online and to improve
cooperation on it among the member
states to better match job supply and
demand we need a stronger European
network of employment services to make
the most out of the potential of labour
mobility in order to achieve higher
growth and more jobs we need a true
European placement and recruitment to
supporting a better functioning of the
European labour market youth employment
was also high on the agenda given the
high percentage of young people out of
work across Europe among the topics on
the table were effectiveness of the
youth guarantee scheme which is aimed at
ensuring that all people under 25
receive a quality offer of employment
further education or a traineeship
within four months of leaving school
work on an agreement to increase the
number of women on company boards will
be handed on to the incoming Latvian
presidency which takes over from Italy
on the first of January the aims to
increase the proportion of women among
non-executive board members to forty
percent by 2020